moi je le souhaite parce que je vois
bien on le voit depuis le début que les
collègues de l'opposition de gauche
veulent faire de l'obstruction ils
souhaitent que nous n'allions pas au
bout je pense qu'en réalité
l'obstruction c'est la négation du
Parlement c'est l'auto effacement du
Parlement comme si finalement on
s'appliquait un article 49-3 au Sénat je
crois que quand on est parlementaire on
doit voter la loi le Parlement c'est pas
fait uniquement pour parler pour
discuter il y a une délibération un vote
qui doit être éclairé par les débats
mais l'origine c'est que les débats
doivent servir justement à éclairer le
vote il faut qu'il y ait un vote sinon
en réalité on risque de nourrir l'anti
parlementarisme puisque beaucoup de
Français considéront que à discuter de
façon infinie à ne pas faire notre job
qui est de voter qui est de décider
alors le Parlement ne sert plus à rien
il nous a dit quelle procédure y penser
engager et quand tu le ferait non non il
y a plusieurs procédures c'est
d'ailleurs dans notre règlement il y a
plusieurs articles qui permettent
d'engager des procédures mais il est pas
question qu'on se laisse prendre en
otage par une volonté d'obstruction d'un
oppositions qui est des avis favorables
défavorables qu'on veuille voter contre
c'est pas mon cas mais je comprends
parfaitement et ils sont dans le rôle de
protester ils sont dans leur rôle de
s'opposer on est aussi dans notre rôle
vis-à-vis des Français de vouloir aller
au bout du texte parce que je le dis
aussi à la gauche si vous voulez qu'on
ne voit que l'article 7 ça signifie que
l'article 8 sur les travailleurs
handicapés sur les Invalides c'est
important ça pour les Français l'article
9 l'usure professionnelle ceux qui ont
durement peiné pendant toute leur
carrière alors c'est quelque chose qu'on
doit pas discuter et nous on a des
propositions à faire pour améliorer leur
sort l'article 10 les petites retraites
l'article 13 qui crée une nouvelle
assurance vieilles se pour les aidants
au moment où on a en France pratiquement
4 millions d'aidants et donc vous savez
c'est soit pour des enfants handicapés
soit pour des parents qui sont âgés
c'est pas important ça il faut que le
Sénat en débattre il faut que le Sénat
assume son rôle constitutionnel de voter
la loi
[Musique]